Hi, I'm Devon.
Today, I'm going to walk you through
how I restore a 200-year-old
grandfather clock.
[clock chiming]
Clocks that old weren't branded
with anything other than
just the clockmaker's name.
A single person built the entire thing.
This particular one is Abraham
Shaw of Billingborough.
So an English clock.
My customer brought it
from England to the US.
She inherited this from her parents,
who inherited it from their parents,
who inherited it from
their parents, back to,
ballpark, 1820s.
Pre-restoration, this clock
is probably not worth much.
I'd say maybe $500 at most. Probably less.
The case definitely is in the need of
more attention than the mechanism.
The whole case has come apart.
I like to start with a cleaning,
just to make sure there's not going to be
any kind of dust or debris,
or, with all clocks, spiderwebs,
that's going to be in the
way of re-gluing everything.
The next step after I clean it
is start approaching
some of the wood repairs.
I almost never have to fix a
case this bad of condition.
This case was in serious need of help.
The parts of a clock case,
the names of them vary.
Each country would call
them different things.
But typically for an English clock,
you would have the
bonnet, which is the hood.
Basically just slides off.
It has the front door to it
and then typically some type of decoration
to make the clock look nice.
Then you have the trunk,
which is just the main body of the clock,
where if you have a door
you could see the
pendulum and the weights.
The base of the clock is the bottom,
the bottom square section.
The floor of the clock was broken,
and half of it missing.
So I just do a couple quick
measurements on the inside
and cut out a new piece.
This is the most common broken
thing on grandfather clocks.
If there's some type of
failure from the weights,
the weights come crashing down,
and when you get a 200-year-old clock,
chances are it's missing the bottom.
So I attach the floor to the base
by using glue and nails.
And then the nails just
help the glue dry properly.
The top right trim piece of the hood
is often in very bad condition.
I was left with decisions to make there,
and I just decided to
keep the original piece.
It was a little difficult to tell
what was actually the
cause of that top corner,
but my best guess, and
a few other clockmakers
that gave me an idea, was
most likely bugs of some sort,
and then if it rotted from there.
The first thing I needed
to do was copy its profile.
There was no good place
to copy it on this piece
because it was damaged
pretty much all over.
So I just went to the back
edge of the other side
and just used a piece
of paper and a pencil,
and I'd just get the
profile for that piece.
And then I glue that to
another piece of wood
to cut that shape out.
And that piece of wood
is what we will end up
calling a form tool.
And then I use
a combination of Bondo
wood filler and paint
just to get it close to
the right color initially.
And, of course, this clock
would've been stained originally,
so to try to match that look
I just used a combination of
brown, red, and black paint
to mimic the wood grain as best I could.
I mix that up with the hardener
and apply it on in large,
copious amounts onto the piece
and make sure it's all rubbed in
to all the nooks and crannies,
so it's going to make a
good joint everywhere.
And then I use that form tool that I made
to basically wipe off the excess
other than where I want it.
I wouldn't call it fabrication,
but I did have to, for
lack of better terms,
fabricate that piece.
And then I cut it off to size.
So I give it a 45-degree
angle on the front
where it will meet the other piece
and then cut the back off just straight
where it will be at the back of the clock.
And then I glue it down.
In this case, I did not use wood glue
because I used Bondo wood filler
and I didn't want the wood filler
to make it so the joint
would not be strong.
So I used a general-purpose
glue, everything type of glue,
which I wouldn't use on
something load-bearing,
but this is just an ornate
decorative piece on the side.
So that glue will be sufficient for that.
Nine times out of 10,
wood glue is going to be your best option.
There's a lot of odd shapes on this,
so it's not easy to clamp.
Clamps have to be
opposite from each other,
and you don't always
have that availability.
So I usually use weights or
something like that in place.
Easily the hardest part of this case,
easily the hardest part, was the glass.
That could have been glazed
in place 200 years ago,
and then at some point during its life,
then that glass broke,
so I'm left with a bunch of glazing
that's full of glass
shards all throughout it.
So there's no great way to
get that old glazing out.
The method I use is
just take a razor blade
and scrape it out.
You know, take your time going
around the whole perimeter.
Clean up as you go to make
sure none of the glass shards
are going to hurt the piece of wood.
Removing that previous glazing
is very tedious and can hurt you.
And then I put the glass in.
And then I use a couple nails
to hold the glass in while I glaze it.
And it's straightforward
but definitely requires a steady hand.
I, in between, do work on the mechanism,
so, you know, disassemble it.
Disassembly takes a lot of focus.
You have to make sure
you're paying attention
to where things are
and if you see any kind
of previous repairs,
because previous repairs are
usually a sign of disaster.
A lot of beginner clockmakers or hobbyists
are tempted to not
disassemble the movement
and dunk it straight into
the ultrasonic cleaner
thinking that it'll clean it.
You know, it's in there.
But you do need to take everything apart.
Not as much for cleaning
but more so for rinsing
and drying afterwards.
The solution will go in
between the little tiny parts
if they're still together,
and it won't come back out
when you try to rinse it.
You gotta take everything apart
down to the very last screw,
every last pin, and clean it that way
in the ultrasonic solution,
which needs to be clock-cleaning solution.
If it's just brass-cleaning solution
or something along those lines,
you can flash-rust the steel.
Or if you use steel-cleaning solution,
you can actually corrode the brass.
It sits there for, ballpark, 20 minutes.
That solution stays on
the parts for too long,
it will ruin them.
So you have to very, very thoroughly
rinse it all off with water.
And then water is just
as bad as the solution
if you don't dry it off.
If you get a little bit of
water stay stuck in a corner,
it'll destroy the clock
within a matter of a couple of years.
Now I'm going to repair the mechanism.
I start working on the pendulum.
The pendulum was already in
pieces when I received it.
The bob of the pendulum, the
brass circle at the bottom,
is actually how we determine
how fast or slow a clock will run.
So it needs to be able to
slide up and down smoothly,
without any kind of
snagging or getting stuck.
So I had to remove a very
small amount of material
from the rod to make sure
the bob could go up and down
and then polish that surface to make sure
it's as close to frictionless as possible.
I actually found some witness marks
on this particular clock.
On the rod, there were
some lines scratched,
and I just went ahead and assumed
that that's where they wanted
the pendulum bob set to.
So I went ahead, set it right there,
and put the screw on underneath it,
and it actually worked first try.
So that witness mark was correct.
Next, I am polishing the pivots.
I'm not focusing on the gear.
I'm actually focusing on
the arbors for the gears.
At the end of each arbor,
there is a pivot point that it
will turn inside the plates.
Its axle, basically.
Clock parts have a lot of terminology
that don't match up with today.
Gears are not called gears,
they're called wheels.
Axles are not called axles,
they're called arbors.
I use a lathe, which is convenient
because it turns
everything concentrically.
Makes everything a lot easier
and turns out nicer in the end.
A lathe is actively trying
to kill you at all times.
If you touch it, it will not stop.
So I keep my fingers out
of the way by using paper.
And then if I have enough room,
I actually use very fine abrasive stones
like an Arkansas stone,
which is just very fine, fine grit.
We're talking around 4,000 grit.
If you leave jagged edges,
it doesn't happen overnight,
but over the course of a few years
the clock will actually eat itself away
if it's not smooth, smooth surfaces.
The other end of them is their bearings
inside the plates.
There's little holes in the plates.
Those need the same process.
They need to be cleaned very thoroughly
and then made sure that
they're polished properly
where it'll have very little friction.
The escapement pallet is going to be
one of the most-ignored things in a clock,
but arguably the most important.
This is what the pendulum is
attached to at the very top.
That groove,
that's a fraction of the
thickness of a human hair.
It's really, really small.
The escape wheel has been hitting that
over and over again for many, many years.
The clock will not run accurately
if those grooves are there.
Most people, when they repair
clocks, will ignore this.
But I go ahead and
re-polish those surfaces.
We're putting in brass cable.
When I picked it up, it
already had brass wire,
but originally it would've
had cat-gut cable,
which would've been made out of cat guts.
That's exactly what it sounds like.
We use brass instead of steel,
because steel cable will actually tear up
the parts inside the clock.
But brass is what the
parts are made out of,
so it's hard to tear up brass with brass.
You want this to wrap around
the barrel that it's going onto
the correct amount of times.
And you also want it to have the weights
reach the bottom of
the case in eight days.
This is an eight-day movement.
There's a few things
you've got to be careful of
when assembling the mechanism.
So, the obvious one
of make sure everything's
in the right place,
but that's actually a lot less
like a puzzle than you think.
If you know what each part does,
it only has one place to go.
And then the difficult
part is indexing it,
where you don't just put
it in the right spot,
but it needs to be oriented
correctly when it goes there.
So you need to have one part of the gear
meshing with another part of the gear.
All those pivots that we
polished are very fragile.
So when you are putting
the plates together,
you have to be very careful
and use very small amounts of force
to try to nudge everything into its place
and make sure that the pivots
go into the correct holes
and aren't damaged.
That's definitely the
art of fixing the clock,
is trying to close the plates.
It takes a certain feel.
Once it's together, then you
get it up on the test stand
and make sure it's still working right.
[clock chiming]
And then there's actually a
several-week period of testing.
Every time I come into the shop,
I see if it's running fast or
slow and make an adjustment.
Usually when I test it there,
I like to get it to where
everything is working
completely properly for
a whole week straight.
Then I put it into the
case to test it there,
to make sure it's all going
to continue to work properly.
Time at the workbench,
I spent probably around two weeks or so
actually working on stuff.
You know, and that's, I'm
talking full hours of two weeks.
I'm pretty happy with this restoration.
Definitely the movement was, you know,
everything went according
to plan, how I liked.
The most satisfying part
of this restoration,
and every restoration,
is definitely going to
be one of two things.
Either the first time the clock ticks,
you know, when I set it up and it works.
That's extremely satisfying
to have that happen.
And the other part is the client
when I deliver it back.
It's extremely satisfying
to see these people's reactions.
Sometimes, for clocks
that are chiming clocks,
I'll bring it back and
they haven't heard it chime
since they were 8 years old
in their grandparents' house.
[clock chiming]
You're only the temporary
caretaker of this clock.
It's been around for 200 years.
It's going to outlive you.
So it's more important to do
what is right for the clock.
I try to keep it original
as much as I possibly can at all times.